[Applaudissements]
mais tu est extrêmement vide je t'adore
bouger mais je sais que tu te cherches
capillairement alors qu'on est d'accord
on n'est pas franchement lui rafraîchir
un petit peu maintenant peu de couleurs
alors là c'est pas rafraîchi là donc
c'est de la merde voilà mais vous êtes
beaucoup mieux comme ça veut dire tenter
demain on revient on va on va on va
tâtonner on va trouver on va trouver ça
essayer de trouver qui est l'oise
hauteur on offre 1000 euros je vous le
dis à la personne qui trouvera qui
éloize auteurs hashtag tpp oiseaux
sauteur voilà regarder voilà apparemment
il
oui voilà vous l'avez reconnu je n'y
peux rien je trouve les ailes vous nous
ferez votre proposition tout à l'heure
on verrait que je le dirai avant 20
heures trois jolies adacore bâti bébé
alors comme chaque soir ma chronique
durant environ deux heures j'ai fait
modifier mon contrat je serai désormais
payer à la minute
parce que du coup ma chronique mais très
courte ce soir dans une semaine je
rachète tf1 je pense alors ce soir au
programme attention quelle vidéo validé
en train de devenir la nouvelle marie
curie nancy si la rébellion des
chroniqueurs qui ne fait que prendre de
l'ampleur faut vous méfier syrie et
surtout je vous montre en exclusivité
des images de cyril hanouna qui sera en
prime
samedi soir sur tf1 bon coin tout
balancer vous allez voir depuis que tout
va
savez vous ce samedi sur celle que vous
avez cyril rahmouna c'est mons et
rahmouna vous allez voir l'animal alors
je dis que nous sommes se questionnent
la mairie tri alors vous savez que je
passe ma vie sur la toile à rechercher
des vidéos qui le ramdam
j'ai trouvé le mec le plus malchanceux
du monde ça se passe aux états unis et
je remet immédiatement le laurier du
gars qui va remporter la prochaine
édition de lâches comme une bouffée
il va lancer sans délai je n'ai eu au
téléphone
non pas le monsieur lui la bête va très
bien il va très bien
ces conneries là ils s'étaient ça
devient de plus en plus beaux gosses
est-ce que vous souvenez que la semaine
dernière je vous avais montré une image
de kevin o bélie qui avaient des
capacités hors normes en mathématiques
oui j'ai essayé on a vu votre tête hyper
étonné quand kelly avait réussi à
répondre un calcul de niveau cm2 n'ont
sinon je suis désolé racines car il est
bon de le revoir
rien que votre regard c'était magnifique
je les vois tout de suite à racine
carrée souvenez vous allez voir j'adore
jouer sur votre tête est bien la semaine
derrière kevin oublie on a appris que
vous étiez pas seulement une spécialiste
en mathématiques parce qu'on fait depuis
que vous essayez la table vous êtes une
nouvelle personne maintenant quand vous
employez des mots de plus d'une syllabe
syrie les dossiers étonné que s'ils
apprenaient que maxime guinée elle est
couchée que de me fier soir alors que je
remets serena le laurier de la tête sur
laquelle je pourrais zoomer toute ma vie
non pas par nos clercs et et vegan
extrêmes les vegans ne sont pas extrêmes
arrive à avoir un palliatif à la viande
[Musique]
c'est bien qu'il y des nouvelles
[Applaudissements]
souhait mais il s'est retrouvé la table
à changer tu arrives à ouais mais oui
non mais c'était avant c'était poulet au
curry bat ans et marie curie et que ce
soit bravo va très bien non mais c'est
des chiffres et des lettres
commencez-vous à l'abattoir on va la
retrouver sur france3 sexy un labyrinthe
est pas à l'abri d'avoir cela mais aux
mêmes heures que kelly et une motte
était nomade éthicienne averti
littéraire une spécialiste de la
diététique mais c'est surtout une
spécialiste de la rébellion
ça vous savez le prime c'est que la
rébellion c'est comme la gastro ça se
transmet et ça fait chier
et forcément tous les chroniqueurs se
sont insérés dans la brèche et
maintenant si rien n'avait plus aucune
autorité sur ce plateau
pour être clair aujourd'hui vous avez le
temps allait lever d'iphone berne oui
oui vous à l'autorité stéphane bern et
c'est oui c'est pas demain non voyants
et donc même valérie benaïm
effectivement vous clash
alors je remets à serena le laurier de
l'animateur qui se laisse complètement
bouffé par une bande de renard c'est à
dire avec les médecins légistes
j'ai juste fait ce que vous n'avez pas
fait mon chéri des effets je vois deux
normales je vais te le mettre
quand on a fait ce facile à chanter en
france 3 arrive alors qu'on peut je vais
te dire ce que tu commences à quoi elle
fait relève mon fils tu vas rencontrer
maman
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui se passe avec moi c'est
vrai j'ai rallié la raison vous êtes
vous
marc war la réunion des chroniqueurs
c'est bien ce temps les autres je
comprends mais beinheim mais beaucoup
déçu heureusement la mafia pour ça je
suis là pour ça des pissenlits
[Rires]
alors s'il vous savez vous savez animer
je savais unités vous savez dans ces je
vois pas ce que vous ne savez pas faire
dans la vie rien je servirai aussi alors
yacine juste vous savez pas faire c'est
finir l'émission à leur centre ça ouais
ça mais il ya une chose que vous faites
très souvent c'est chanter pour vous
chanter c'est un moyen de de dévoiler
vos sentiments de montrer que derrière
le saltimbanque
il ya un homme sensible arrête parce que
je n'arrête pas de se moquer de moi
parce qu'ils pensent que je me prend
pour un grand show open c'est justement
le truc en premier exactement ce que
vous êtes premiers pas du tout pas du
ccc se prend pas il est donc je serai
sur salem soir sur tf1 samedi soir
pourquoi parce que comme je dis chaque
soir dans l'émission vous adorez chanter
on l'a encore vu à quel instant fia doit
et quand vous chantez vous n'êtes pas du
tout en mode d'art cas alors je vous
remets le laurier du gars qui fait style
qui chantent pour rigoler alors qu'il se
prend vraiment pour un grand chanteur
regardez vous allez voir après 42
minutes
c'est vraiment déçu watts
baba douceur
thomas
aso b b à ba
moi tu le soldat qu'en gp2 russe
les gars c'est pas je vous en donne et
se sont levés du ca sion partition il
faut pas quoi trouvez pas non je vous
avais fait du mal à the writer à cause
de la cause devant son compte que les
talons sont partout on veut les trouver
n'importe quoi s'il vous plaît
n'exagérez pas les gens vont plus de
croire mais pour signer alors forcément
autant de talents de chant ça suffit des
convoitises et les casteurs d'une grande
émission de télé vous en contact et pour
que vous veniez chanter vous êtes un
petit cachottier donc samedi soir vous
serez sur tf1 j'ai les images en
exclusivité vous saurez dans ce volet
nous voici un extrait d'autres
précédents cités qui ça c'était stéphane
plaza
[Rires]
il pleure quand ils voient mes audiences
même aux toilettes il pense à moi quand
je suis peu ninine rit aux éclats
mes amours lui donne des airs pour se
payer des sociétés cotées oh mon dieu
gourde et les mots les millions du tout
est ce que tout change vous avez vous
voulez pas je me déguisais les
prochaines je me fait bien rigoler je le
fais voilà on est du couac est ce cas
ils se retourneront pas du tout ce que
je retourne pas qu'elle va pas trop
enfin paris wellwood et je vais prendre
des cours de chant pendant adacore l'âme
la meilleure alors là oui quoi vous avez
fini je finis par être chez moi tu sais
quoi terminer encore une fois de plus
sur un succès on merci beaucoup et bien
écoutez vous passez une bonne
[Applaudissements]